[Music]
this is strange talk because doesn't
have too much mathematics there's no
game theory and there's no congestion so
you wonder what is there so let's talk
about intersections and it was my
summary the first propositions is that
intersections are the bottlenecks of
urban roads and therefore intersection
signal control which is how you regulate
traffic through the intersection
determines mobility which is throughput
how many people can go through and delay
how much time they spend in the
intersection and there are three sets of
control parameters which determine the
control policy of an intersection
the first one is cycling so I'm going to
define all these in case you never heard
of them the second one is phase
durations so how much green for one
direction versus another and the third
one which is probably less familiar is
offsets that is the displacement of the
beginning of green from one to section
over the next and then I'll move to
adaptive control where the duration
varies depending upon the sense traffic
by the controller and then predicting
how long a particular phase will last
and some applications why people care
about
and so I said intersections are
bottlenecks so let's look at that
intersection sort of a typical foreleg
intersection and in the in those four
legs there are two lanes one for the
three lanes but let's look just look at
the left turn lane and a through lane
the right turn lane I assume is always
permitted so there's no nothing to do
with the intersection control right
because the right turns are always
permitted and so there let's assume so
there's four approaches one through and
one left turn lane a typical number
about how much capacity how much flow
can one lane carry this number to
remember is about 1200 vehicles per hour
right so 1200 vehicles per hour can go
through one particular Lane it may go as
far up as 1800 but that's just for
purposes of this so the access capacity
the number of vehicles which can enter
that intersection is you have 8 possible
lanes to in each approach so 8 times
1200 is 9600 vehicles per hour that's
the access capacity of that intersection
however the intersection can only allow
two of these movements at any given time
which are non conflicting otherwise
you'll have a mess right so only two are
permitted so that means the intersection
will permit at most two times 1200 or
2,400 vehicles per hour which is 25% of
the access capacity so the intersection
is the bottleneck right it can only
carry one quarter of the throughput dad
the roads can bring to it so the
performance of the road network is
determined principally by how the access
to the intersection is controlled all
right that's usually by means of signals
either you have green in which case you
can go or it's red in which case you
shouldn't go and so the signal control
parameters are something cycle length
and the phase plan the phase durations
and the offsets so this particular
intersection where each movement is
called a phase so there's eight phases
the odd numbers ones correspond to turns
and the even-numbered ones corresponding
to three movements right so that's just
something to remember if something you
talk to a traffic engineer and he says
phase one and phase five are actuated at
the same time that means two left turns
are actuated at the same time so
typically in a phase plan you'll have to
face that are actuated get a green at
the same time then you switch to another
two and then you switch to another two
and another two alright so that's how
these eight phases will get actuated and
then you come back to the beginning of
the cycle so a cycle will consists of
sequence of pairs of phases that get
actuated the amount of time that this
pair for instance is actually it is
called the duration of that phase that's
the phase duration and the total cycle
time coming back is called a cycle time
and typically I'm going to assume and
that's the case in most places the cycle
time as you come back is fixed there's a
reason for fixing that but we'll get to
that so for instance this may have a
total cycle time of 120 seconds or two
minutes and you may spend 30 seconds in
each phase normally that's not the case
in the more heavily travel direction you
have a longer duration and then the
others
so now so you can think about if you're
queuing theorists that this intersection
consists of two servers right for the
two directions and it can end their
eight queues and it can provide serve
two queues at a time but not any two
queues because they can t they have to
be non conflicting I cannot serve this Q
and this Q at the same time so the pairs
of queues that I'm allowed to serve that
looks like a standard queueing problem
there's one hitch and that is every time
you switch that switch from this to the
turns there is something called an
Allred clearance so two greens before I
switch to another two greens I have to
have everybody read right it's usually
three seconds called an Allred clearance
so that the vehicles who are not very
alert who are in the intersection when
the phases switch they get time to get
out of there right so that's wastage
right and so three seconds is wasted
every time you're clear yep for me I'm
the surviving right turns in case the
right turns are have a signal then they
usually enormous in terribly the right
turn is permitted at the same time as
the true movement but for my discussion
I'm just assuming that the right turn is
permitted at any time so they don't
offer you any problems in terms of usage
of the intersection so if you have a
switching horeb I mean serving
discipline the switching creates a big
problem I mean most of your service in
theorems of server write multiprocessor
whatever failed breakdown so there's an
obvious thing to do so supposing is this
cycle was 100 seconds and I'm going to
there's gonna be four switches per cycle
so I'm going to waste 12 seconds in all
red so that's a wastage of 12 percent so
the obvious thing to do is to extend the
cycle if I make cycle 200 seconds
again you've just waste for time to the
red so I want to again waste 12 seconds
so that's a wastage of 6 seconds so the
thing to do is to increase your cycle
then the waste goes down but people
don't like increase they're gonna wait
for 2 minutes or 3 minutes so 4 minutes
so that's one problem that people get
upset for a long cycle but more
importantly there's a long cycle then
there's also a long red and if there's a
long red the queues build up and the
queues may build up and saturate and
effect the previous signal right so you
have to compromise you have you want a
long cycle to reduce the wastage but you
want a short cycle to prevent queues
from building up so that's an issue
about how big a cycle length you should
create typically if there's a lot of
traffic then you'll find that in most
cities the cycling increase because now
you have a lot of traffic so if you give
them too much red you even saturate the
signal and if there's very little
traffic at middle of night the cycles
are normally shorter so people don't
wait there's no reason to make them wait
because there's plenty of capacity yeah
so I'll come to the adaptive part but
the adaptive parts adaptive part is
principally for phase durations are
adapted not at the cycle time and the
cycle time I kept fixed and for a reason
we'll come to which is offsets so
offsets require a fixed cycled I'm ok
so thanks plant determines which
sequence in which they operated
now the duration how do I fix the
duration so that's appalling so let's
take a phase I we have somehow the other
managed to fix the cycle time T hundred
seconds two hundred seconds whatever it
is then so the phase I G sub I is the
fraction of time in the cycle that that
direction gets a green okay
so G sub R is the green time so G sub I
divided by T is the fraction of cycle
devoted to Phase I Green S sub I is some
magical number called the service rate
if we're queueing theories but normally
it's called a saturation flow rate by
the traffic engineers but it's exactly
the service rate which says that if
nothing else is going on and you had an
infinite queue and this guy was green
all the time you SI vehicles per hour
would go in that direction okay so
that's a sub I so you have to select
these G sub i's that's the face duration
S sub I is a physical thing depending
upon the width of the road etc whether
that's a great or not great so S sub R
is given physically t you've already
decided so you have to pick G sub I
train which is the sum of the GI and the
sum of the total green time you have is
the total cycle time minus the loss due
to the red clearance so it's a
straightforward problem right so this is
this is called a fixed time control I'm
gonna fix G sub I for every cycle
there's nothing adaptive here alright
it's a fixed time control and so the G
sub R is a constant that you will select
and they must be chosen to accommodate
the demand so depending upon how much
demand there is approach in true
directions from south to north which is
east to west you have to select select
the G sub I so that C sub I will be
larger than your demand okay I'll give
you the demands it's a straightforward
problem to figure out C sub I there's
some flexibility as to how you should
choose GI
and because you have you hopefully
total rate available is larger than your
demand then you can distribute the X
access either for in all directions or a
particular direction with its greater
uncertainty about the demand and so on
offset so here is six intersections and
they're connected now let's look at this
direction from west to east so this
phase this would be a two-phase so we'll
have a number two four six eight at
suppose it's phase two so phase two
let's say starts at time zero in a cycle
alright so just do everything modulo the
cycle so it starts at zero vehicles will
they just got released this phase will
start at some time maybe zero maybe some
other time you don't want it to start at
zero what you want to do if it takes a
certain travel time to hit here then you
want this offset to be exactly equal to
that travel time then you get a green
wave I started green it takes me five
seconds to get here or ten seconds to
get here then I want this green to start
ten seconds after this one clear and
this takes seven seconds so on this
green to start
seven seconds up to that one so that's
the displacement of the beginning of
green is called the offset and the
offsets are very critical because that
determines whether everybody I mean if
it's bad offset than ever I only hit the
red light every time I cross and if it's
good synchronized so called then I get a
green wave
we assumed implementation wise that
there's a common global process so
implementation wise there's somewhere
some intersection doesn't matter
somebody so these offsets are set by a
traffic management center okay which
says right now is zero and the sack of
time is hundred twenty and you will
start at zero you're you're
synchronizing phase which I said in this
case is phase two you start ten seconds
later at twenty seconds later and so on
so it looks easy but there's a problem
yeah so can offsets also be dynamic it
can it can absolutely and so you should
be it should be dynamic all right that
should be done but I'll come to making
things so dynamic right which but before
I get to that even the static age
there's a problem the problem is if I go
around the loop I'm coming back at the
same point in the cycle so theta 1 2
plus theta 2 3 / 4 3 2 plus theta 2 1
must be a multiple of the cycle that's
an integer constraint on the second is
that clear right has to be a multiple of
the cycle because I'm coming back and
everything is modular cycle time so I
should come back at the same point I
think this physically right this is 10
seconds this is 26 physically it should
end if I'm starting synchronizing the
green the beginning of green then no
matter which way I come around I should
end up with the multiple of that green
that's a common authorial constraint on
this right makes the problem difficult
well no such I'm not making any such
assumption because the speed here may be
faster than the speed here right if this
is the commute direction this will be
slow and that's nobody there so the
speed travel time from here to here may
be higher or lower so even in the this
case it doesn't have to be obvious right
but indeed if I'm just worrying about
one arteriole with one north-south and
one southeast south north it's easier
problem even the common story problem
easy but when I have a network like a
grid this becomes difficult okay now
ideally as you said it should be changed
but just imagine you are the traffic
engineer and you are told
ok now your offset is increased by 10
seconds you cannot implement it
immediately you are because the motorist
aren't used to sudden change I expect
this to be green for so long and now all
of a sudden you're either increasing it
or decreasing my green time and that so
it takes some time over typically 5 10
cycles you bring in the new plan into
operation all right number one number
two you need the data to be able to
figure out what the travel time is and
number three this problem is not easy to
solve so it's not obvious what is the
right offset okay but I'm not going to
consider offsets but just to give you
what is the basics so the basic
translation engineering signal control
problem is just what I said
offsets cycle time phase duration
now
I'm gonna do everything with this
particular intersections this
intersection has six phases denoted P 1
P 2 P 3 etc P 1 and P 5 are odd number
so they're the left turn P 2 and P 6 are
the main through routes and P 4 and P 8
are the other ones the the true in the
minor direction P 3 and P 7 are not
there so that so P 3 and P 7 would be a
left turn so as some assumption is that
if I want to make a left turn I wait for
this green and make a left so it's so
called permissive green permissive left
okay so there are only six phases in
this two phases are missing or have zero
time and let's suppose the plan is that
P 4 and P 8
I'm just do ya people want P 8 which is
the true direction for the - it come
first then come P 1 and P 5 the two left
turns and then P 2 and P 6 the two major
through movements I've run them
purposely this way to denote that this
duration and these durations can be
varied okay so that's called actuated
signal or adaptive duration so they can
be varied we're worried about how they
are varied but the cycle time is fixed
so whatever variation you get has to be
if you have extra amount of time you
give it to the major direction if you
have less time you'd steal it from the
major direction so that's a standard
actuated control how do you decide
whether to give more to be for P 8 or P
1 P 5 well you have detectors the
detectors in the ground measure how much
traffic demand there is it's all
imperfect right but anyway that's what
it's supposed to measure how much
traffic demand there is in this
direction in that direction and the
traffic is higher than you expect then
you give it some more green all right if
I have more left turns and I expect I
give the left turns
Green and if there's less I turn the
green to red and give the extra time to
the true move
that's an actuated signal increasingly
more and more signals becoming actuated
provide some adaptive 'ti because if I
notice that there is more demand in here
but it's not long turn adaptation
there's no algorithm which is going to
estimate the demand that is coming and
doing that everything is sort of one
cycle to cycle three cycle horizons
that's the current practice you would
say it is possible that if I see a lot
more here then I know that they will
show up in the next intersection so I
can use that to give more time to the
true movement in that direction okay so
that is done so several commercial
packages look at two three intersections
and decide okay but
if this is variable then you cannot
predict when my green will happen right
now you may not care but it is useful
and so that's where I want to go in an
actuated signal so so I'm going to look
at the durations so just blessed I'm
just looking at one direction all right
the major direction so I'll ignore this
one but the same calculation goes in the
other one so what I want to do is to
predict
so at any time T in the cycle I want to
predict this is the phase 4 and p4 and
is the end of that phase for someone so
it's the end of green or the beginning
of the next thread or the end of that so
I want to predict at this time T how
much time is remaining in the phase 4
how much time is remaining in phase 1
which is the remaining phase 1 plus that
etc so these phases are no longer fixed
time so it's not 20 seconds 40 seconds
60 seconds but maybe 20 seconds plus or
minus something and 40 seconds plus or
minus something and that's a random
thing which depends upon the traffic and
that I don't know how much traffic there
is not only depends upon the traffic but
depends upon how the controller senses
that traffic and what kind of algorithm
it is using to increase or decrease the
green cars I want to predict this using
historical data that is I know
historically this face took this much
time and that's the distribution and now
I want to predict how much time would be
left so that's a straightforward problem
so let's see how these homes may or may
not be able to see this so this data
from that particular intersection so one
vertical line is one cycle ok so I look
at five cycle number 30,000 that's what
happened so this much green with the
duration of phase four
then comes the red which is the duration
of phase one and then the blue is the
residual which is the direction of the
true movement so there are for each
cycle I have three numbers the duration
degree in the duration of the blue and
the rest and there's okay this is the
result of actuation this is a result of
actuation so this is historical data
I measure I mean I get from the
controller or rather from something
which can sense the signal face okay so
that's what I happen
now I'm outside my measurement so this
is what I've already measured and now
I'm in a new cycle and you request for
me phase how long is the green phase
gonna last how much is the blue phase
gonna last
etcetera okay so that's called faith
predicting the face and I want to know
the faith predicting the phase duration
but you don't know the actuation logic
the actual logic is very very difficult
it's it's all in hardware and every
company has its own actuation logic it
also depends upon what actually they're
sensing of the traffic the only thing
you know if it's anything decent then
the greater the traffic the more green
is given but if there's traffic in all
directions then it's unclear who gets
the green all right so typically the the
give you a two-minute description of how
these things work so there's a nominal
there's a minimum green right you have
to have a minimum green I'm you want to
make sure that the fact that a vehicle
gets through that intersection so
there's a minimum green that's one
parameter the second parameter is
so-called extension so every time it
sees the vehicle going through it
extends that minimum green that's a 2
seconds per sensor up to a maximum you
don't want to steal everything from the
other vehicles the other phases so
there's a maximum and then there's an
early cut off so if you find that the
two vehicles the successive vehicles
took more than four seconds you assume
nobody else is coming and you early
return to it so you send the green to
the other one so these are the three
main parameters right the minimum green
so-called extension and a gap out or a
max gap out means the two successive
vehicles took more than four seconds or
whatever the gap are so that's roughly
the logic
okay so now we're looking at phase four
so what is phase four
so phase 4 is this green that was a true
traffic now there's what you'll notice
is that green there's at least gives you
minimum this much right and why is that
and that is because it's a fairly wide
street and this green which is so when
this is green the restrooms are allowed
to cross but that shouldn't have to make
it to the other end safely so there's a
minimum green which is given for the
pedestrians all right beyond the minimum
green depends upon how much traffic
there is so that's the minimum green
okay
so you can take the histogram of d4 and
see that its minimum at least this much
that's for this pedestrians and then it
goes up and it's got the shape the shape
the histogram so the shape comes from
notice an extra vehicle and so the extra
vehicles so that this probability times
of the green that extended and so on
okay
now we're somewhere T seconds into the
phase p4 right so still green anyone
know how long it will continue well
there's an obvious thing you do right at
any time T if you already if you're here
so 34 seconds have passed in that phase
and you're you are required to predict
to the vehicle how long that phase will
last what will you do you take the
expected value of the remaining duration
given at time T if T equal to 30 you do
what is the prediction of d4 it's still
green so d4 beyond 30 so that's your
best prediction or a prediction okay the
best if you do mean square or something
like that that's the conditional
expectation of the remaining duration so
here here this would be a buck of your
prediction but if you pass that you'll
worry much later right so what will it
look like
let's go back to the prediction the
expected value would be around 38 if you
are somewhere here forgotten whatever
the time is but beyond that Maya
prediction is increased if you have
already past 36 and so on alright so if
you work it out that's what the
prediction will be so if you are the
prediction provider you need in you or
whatever some lookup table the time and
if already 38 seconds have gone by and
you're still green then you'd say the
last up to 42 so the remaining duration
is 42-38 so all right so that's your
best prediction
some interesting thing if you look so
this is not the duration remaining
duration d4 minus T and what you observe
is initially it'll decrease of course
time has gone by so you expect the
remaining duration to decrease but then
all of a sudden your best prediction
goes up because you pass that smaller
thing and now the next big probability
is somewhere there alright so and then
goes back again this is like your file
downloads right and the time goes down
five seconds four seconds two seconds
and all of a sudden goes up to five
seconds etcetera now so the residual
phase duration may increase or decrease
that's the nature of the actuated signal
now one reason people are proposing that
they should have a spat intersection
should provide you this bad signal is
for so-called eco driving so eco driving
is I've arrived at the beginning of the
intersection and I want to go through
the rest of the street and most of the
energy is consumed in acceleration and
braking if I know that this thing will
be green in 20 seconds from now then I
can adjust my velocity profile so I
don't do acceleration and braking and
make it in the green window so that
requires me to tell you this bad
prediction but this kind of story
because the prediction fluctuates makes
it difficult to do eco driving so out is
now announced they they have something
called a countdown timer which gives you
the how long the green will last or when
the green will start one way or the
other and but the it cannot be just a
countdown timer it it also has to allow
count up in the thing so I'm not sure
exactly what the
mean by that okay so let's see how you
do this eco-driving so how would you
design the variable speed profile of the
speak all going through that link so
this is the naive user who's that
informed doesn't know and the red is
going to happen when the green is going
to happen and it started the the whole
thing is 400 meters and it started at 22
meters per second and just goes constant
speed you'll hit red and they'll have to
stay until it hits green and go on so a
lot of energy is going to be wasted in
the braking so that's the so called
naive user
now if you're doing an eco driving so
you are going to design the speed
profile of your vehicle as it goes to
that intersection when it receives the
spat signal so that's the in the
subsequent stuff this is the model for
the fuel consumption which depends upon
the speed and the acceleration of that
particular vehicle and as you expect
it's increasing with speed and increases
with acceleration is negative the
decelerating then you just pay something
constant otherwise that's what you get
so given that we're going to design and
given when the light is going to turn
green we're going to decide sorry hey is
the acceleration
this is decelerating this is
accelerating he said that under your
control this well is that it oh yeah
yeah it is under your control so so I
haven't haven't yet said but this is the
way your fuel is going to be consumed
that's the model of the fuel consumption
so you're gonna go from beginning to end
that's the model of your fuel
consumption so what's the V of T or what
is the a of T and therefore the V of T
which is its integral or how that going
to be designed okay
so here's what the fuel consumption
looks like as a function of speed I
really increases fast with speed now
right typically if you're driving at a
constant speed then the drag is what you
have to combat with gas and that's the
way it goes if it's the acceleration is
1 meters per second and so on okay so
the problem is if I tell you when the
red will change to green so that's the
time T red if I give you that ahead of
time at time zero times zero is when
you're entering this leaving the biggest
intersection and entering the stretch of
road and I'll tell you what that is this
is the amount of fuel you will consume
from T 0 to TF TF is when you reach the
end so D is the D meters is how long
that road is ok so the standard throw
problem perfect information so I tell
you how much 15 seconds 20 seconds
whatever so you want to solve this so
discretize everything so that's the
discrete formulation and you solve about
dynamic programming go backwards we know
what the boundary condition is you have
to reach D here's what it looks like if
you start out that 25 minutes per second
and you want to hit this when you're
green and you don't have to but if you
hit it in red that's bad because I'm on
you're gonna break a lot and waste too
much energy alright so obviously you
should hit it so you just enter the exit
the road when you're in green so that's
what these profiles will look like okay
so if you're starting at time zero
you'll go this way and then you realize
I'm not you realize you know the head of
time so your velocity profile should be
like that okay and then you clear
the intersection at the end here is
becoming Red Deer so you have a squeezed
a little bit you have to make it through
during the green so you have to speed up
a little bit faster than a sheared here
so this all makes perfectly good sense
I'm sorry over here this is the optimal
so yeah I mean there's a trade-off
between speed and acceleration so
there's a you go back this is for an
initial speed of oh I'm sorry that's my
boundary condition I entered this road
at whatever 25 meters per second that's
given that's so different initial speeds
will have different profiles than this
one right speed is too fast in some
sense you have to slow down in that
respect yes yes okay but what is to
fasten was too slow I'm it's too fast
because you see this right but otherwise
this fuel consumption is milliliters per
second but that's not the best what
speed should I go if my low road is very
very long right so I'm not going to hit
that red for a long time then the speed
I should go is the speed which is the
least milliliters per mile not
milliliters per second so to take this
and divided by the speed and so on to
get the optimum so the optimum speed is
somewhere between that slow thing and
the fasting right if it was a long way
to go yeah so a low V goes presumably
we'll just follow you all right so so I
have very little time so let me just
finish the story and so we've done
experiments and the experiments say that
you save up to 20 percent of the fuel
cost okay so here's an example of Q
consumption this is the uninformed user
at 20 miles per hour and this is the
informed user I mean initial speed 25
you save a lot right off and as the
speed becomes the ideal you begin to
save less and less so time this may be
interesting
this is the fuel minimizing trajectory
and that's the naive guy so you do take
longer right if you're minimizing your
fuel and then the time that you take to
reach their life is more than so you are
driving slower than for this particular
example now suppose we have this
interesting case where the prediction
varies as time progresses right and it
may happen that the prediction is in the
middle of you were driving the thing
changes so I won't bother you with that
so then depending upon the number of
steps these people who came here so it
was initially this red this was the time
- then it became this and then it became
this these people unfortunately it's too
late for them so they will have to stay
read these people a little bit better
off and they slowed down but not
sufficiently dependent so on right until
these make it into the green so let me
conclude with one more thing so there
are others bad applications one is in
safety that I think I talked about which
is it'll inform the vehicles how long
this phase will last and what the next
phase will be right so it might you want
to make a left turn you can't do it now
but it'll tell you how long you need to
wait to make a left turn so whether you
should risk it or not alright so that
provides you more importantly to tell
you what are the phases of the other
users because right now you just see
your green or your red and you don't
know whether the other ones can take a
left in front of you or cannot take a
left in front of you so that would give
perhaps a more interesting thing is for
trucks and buses so streets get chewed
up by heavy vehicles your light vehicle
doesn't really affect because the chew
up of the street depends upon the cube
of the weight so five-ton truck will
chew up lots and lots I mean much more
of the roads so at Berkeley if you know
is that only in
you come from Berkeley can use for
Buzzy's at a parking where the bus stop
is there there's an apron of concrete so
the bus comes and stops over there right
because the biggest wear and tear
happens when it's breaking and when it's
accelerating right that's when the
maximum torque on the wheels and that's
when the horn goes to the pavement and
that chews up the pavement trucks are
even worse than buses so if a truck is
coming it knows where it is perhaps from
the GPS so it knows if it gets a signal
saying this thing will last for 15 more
seconds it can adjust or even better
maybe the intersection can give it more
green so that it goes through without
hitting the brakes right
typically buses are given that privilege
so buses have used many many
intersections the buses have a special
signal so the intersection gets saying
the bus is arriving and it may give it
an extend the green for the bus to go
through all right the bus is going squat
in the middle of the red then it's not
going to do that well do that so this
can help a lot in terms of
infrastructure and pavement lifetime so
I'll stop over there yeah
[Applause]
in the morning people go to work and
then evening they come back you should
adjust the offsets and you should adjust
the durations exactly according to I
mean you should take it into account so
typically in terms of durations
controller signal controller has space
for sixteen different patterns and they
hire a consultant to figure out when the
morning commute time where they should
start that 6:00 a.m. at 10:00 a.m. and
then the middle midday and evening and
so on right you'll be much better I mean
you have to know what the traffic volume
is right so but if you had those
measurements and now they're not
difficult to get then you should have
those adjusted on the fly as it were
right in in in real time and even though
there's a commute pattern still in maybe
15 seconds 15 minutes early or 15
minutes late and if you know that you
can change those timing and get a big
advantage in terms of throughput and
reduction and delay so you ought to do
that so if you go to your city you
should tell the traffic get in you do
may get adaptive right because I mean
today collecting that data is easy it's
not Google style data right I mean you
have to you need volumes it's not just
where the travel time but you need
volumes and
you should do that and we've nice if you
develop algorithms can do that offset as
the traffic pattern changes because
that's a difficult problem yeah
robustness with respect to say
disruption and I'm thinking like
Mountain Avenue and I to ten clubs there
isn't right but that is certainly
affects travel times and so it should
affect offsets and maybe it should also
affect the durations because you know
this thing is blocked so there's no
point giving it green all right but
there isn't
so the main reason to have a fixed cycle
time is just to make the offset problem
yes otherwise there's no offset doesn't
make any sense right slightly flexible
in cycle time than the offset problem
also might become I don't see that I
know they're offset problem is ideally
you want the offset to equal your travel
time right so you get a green wave and
indeed the travel time changes
continuously right now I understand that
but you cannot change the offset come to
you see I mean this is centrally has to
broadcast and and it may be the travel
time this one it's gone from ten seconds
to twelve but the next one hasn't so
yeah so and the offset is I mean you
have to adjust all the offset at the
same time as it were right
coming from supporting infrastructure
all is it's sort of some kind of
wireless communication and sensory data
between the smart vehicles and the
signal or for this well I'm not sure
entirely I mean you know but then I have
to wait forever right for the smart
vehicles to show up if I you know living
a reasonably sized city in China these
days they already have a countdown
so I'm saying you should use that but
that that that is possible because they
have fixed time right
but in this app so I agree with you
completely that you do not need
connected vehicles you can have timers
everybody uses the timer's on the
crosswalk right to give you some idea of
how long that green or red is gonna last
well make it explicit then you can
adjust it much more than sorry I have
nothing I'm not saying that you need to
to to be connected I'm also saying that
you can also put on a little
something what the next phase is going
to look like who is going to get the
right of way
after the five seconds when your timer
is over so I'm not I'm not at all
insisting that you need to be connected
in order to take advantage of this
[Applause]